history has been made in the united
states katanji brown jackson becomes the
first black woman to be confirmed to the
u.s supreme court the 51-year-old
federate appellate judge was nominated
by president joe biden who hailed her
appointment as a historic day for
america but most republicans did not
vote to confirm her
the a's are 53
the nays are 47
and this nomination is confirmed
after a 233-year wait a black woman will
soon sit on the u.s supreme court
katanji brown jackson watched herself
enter the history books from the white
house alongside president joe biden who
hailed her confirmation as a historic
moment for the us
just three republican senators voted
with the democrats to confirm brown
jackson as only the third black person
and sixth woman to serve on the us's
highest court the vote concluded a
bitterly partisan approval process that
saw brown jackson grilled by republican
senators on hot button issues like race
relations and abortion as well as her
record as a judge
senate democrats were overjoyed by the
result
it is just an amazing day
if i had to think of an adjective to
describe all of us it would be elated
elated because of this wonderful person
going on the court this has been a long
hard road
as we try to get to greater equality
less bigotry in america
and there is often steps backward but
when you have a day like this it
inspires you to keep moving forward
brown jackson is set to replace stephen
breyer when he retires at the end of the
court's current term but with the
conservatives set to maintain their 6-3
majority she may find it difficult to
make much impact on the increasingly
right-wing court
our next guest is michelle goodwin she's
a law professor and executive committee
member of the aclu she joins us now from
irvine california miss goodwin thank you
for being with us on the day in the
history of the united states judge
jackson is now the 116th person to
ascend to the supreme court and the
first black woman what went through your
mind as vice president kamala harris
confirmed that vote yesterday
this is history in the making and it's a
day to celebrate but it's also was a day
to reflect there have only been five
women to serve on the united states
supreme court and that deserves deep
reflection of what that court's history
has been and the history of
blocking women quite literally from
becoming even lawyers and legislation
upheld by the supreme court
that would block women from becoming
lawyers such that the path would be
in fact such a hard road and that in
233 years we've had only five women
to serve on this august body
and only two black people
to serve on this body and she will be
the third and so while it represents
a moment to celebrate the grand
accomplishments the sterling meritorious
record
of judge jackson we also have some very
serious reflection and work to do in the
united states not only based on what we
saw during the senate judiciary
confirmation hearings which were
appalling
but also what this represents in terms
of our history and the road to go to
forge greater equality
you mentioned her stellar record her
credentials her experience two degrees
from harvard graduated with honors a
former public defender i don't even have
time to go through this list in this
conversation but as you mentioned during
the senate confirmation hearing she was
repeatedly questioned by some
republicans in a way that black women
are often questioned despite their very
clear accomplishments what struck you as
you watch this process unfold
it was a spectacle and again if we pay
attention to history it's a spectacle
that has its very origins in the very
beginnings of u.s history and slavery
and through jim crow
that when senators could no longer ping
her on merit let's be clear when
president biden said that he would
nominate a black woman to the united
states supreme court
there were social media messages and
interviews that it would be a lesser
person lesser than that this would be a
person who wouldn't be able to
distinguish between a fashion catalog
and a legal case book all of that really
excoriating scurrilous kinds of attacks
not even knowing who he would nominate
and then she turns out to have this
record a record that is so exceptional
that it exceeds that of the people who
currently sit on the court when they
were first nominated and that says a lot
about how the expectations for black
women must be that you must be actually
more qualified and overqualified for
some of these positions and yet be
regarded and treated with such
indignity and disdain and part of that
was just really heartbreaking i think
not only for black women to see but i
think that americans were really
repulsed by that such that she came away
out of those hearings where she was
graceful and poised and dignified and so
incredibly smart in how she answered
questions that americans now rate her as
the most favored judicial candidate in
more than a generation and i think that
it was reflection not only in terms of
how she carried herself during the
hearings but it was also a reflection of
just the very um awful treatment that
she experienced by some republican
members of the senate judiciary
committee
and there were only three republicans
who voted to confirm her we speak often
of a divided america particularly in
recent years what does this vote tell us
about that division in your country
this vote tells us that the republican
party is no longer the republican party
of reagan of bush or of any president
before
this is a tea party uh type of
republican party and one can see that in
just the ideology of where the
republican party is going if you think
about an issue such as reproductive
rights which is an issue that's under
attack now roe v wade was a seven to two
opinion
five of those justices of the seven were
republican appointed justice blackman
who wrote the opinion in roe v wade was
put on the court by richard nixon uh a
car carrying member who was republican
and so you see the ideologies and
principles and values of the party
actually changing and we see now it's
less of a reagan party and it is more of
a jesse helms party and jesse helms his
record speaks for itself
with justice jackson to be justice
jackson on the bench now it is still a
conservative majority
there's a lot of concern in the united
states now about roe v versus wade which
you just brought up how likely is it
that the supreme court will overturn roe
versus wade in the coming
months well we don't know exactly but
many people are quite worried as they
should be so in texas there is a law
that's been allowed to go into effect
it's a ban on abortions after six weeks
of pregnancy a time in which most people
won't know that they're pregnant it
makes no exceptions for cases of rape or
incest and again this is the kind of
legislation that 10 years ago one would
never have seen 15 years ago never would
have seen
but this is part and parcel of what we
see coming out of states that are
republican dominant now on this court
it's a super majority republican
appointed court that in the past would
have meant nothing but these are
justices that have articulated
personally and also from the bench um
that they would like to see roe v wade
overturned some of them and so this is a
possibility now but it is also a
possibility that it may just simply be a
death by a thousand strikes michelle
goodwin a law professor in the united
states thank you very much
thank you